the Pete Holmes
I made that new year's rent I've made a
couple new year's resolutions even
though I don't like the holiday met a
couple I'd like to summon some Grecian
warriors to battle by blowing into an
enormous support of some spiders and
you're lying to yourself if you don't
think you want to do that too high
there's no follow-up so now I know that
right now I think that stupid human self
deception no I don't know like different
friend in Yeti which I know is
ridiculous but I think they put this I
think for nothing fun yeah yeah if he's
in the snow easy I was picturing not in
the snow though which is weird that you
knew that and it is a Bigfoot man or a
sasquatch
but I think of a friend which I know is
a strange concept but I think would be
very rewarding just like the first three
weeks are like just trying to teach it
to not Maul you you know you're like I
have berries and you're grooming it than
running in this big stupid Sasquatch
space that he's learning like I think
that would be a very nice crowning
moment a very fulfilling life moment
where you know you've connected with the
Yeti just looks at you those friends I
want that so much more than anything
that having any look at me very
sincerely
don't worry isn't like about what he was
just saying first of all and whenever I
say I like things about when he just
said it means that I find them strange
I like that he's grooming and then
running during the stage where you're
teaching the Bigfoot not to kill you
it's like but it still gotta look good
you know
if I got company my daddy needs to be in
the room like it's just like don't kill
me please but if you see there his coat
is shining and he's he can tell on his
big stupid face that he's learning first
of all if you talk about him in that
language he said we're gonna learn
self-confidence let me let me make that
very clear to everybody in here let that
be a lesson to those of you raising yet
easier children he's finally let's go
back at the beginning when you berated
me for saying that a sasquatch is
something he's like oh that's been there
in the snow
what kind of nerdy mythological crap is
that
but I might yeah Bigfoot he's like if it
was in the snow
I raised this loser but Yeti is I read
Tintin that's where you got most if
you're ready knowledge of Bigfoot I
think the guy who wrote Tintin was a
Nazi is that true like one person over
here confirmed it and do it and do it
before he walked in here even walk
around today guy was a Nazi I know that
he came what do you do what kind of
stuff I think where did you come across
that it's Rennes France it's all over
it's just racist comics I like to go to
French people I go
well I haven't tried it if you don't
know how great that is right
you're again practicing self deception
you're lying yourself because it's
cleansing and over there doing each
other ha ha ha people with a successful
trip
a lot further apart